here the uncomparable Steven A Smith and
to help me with the week 14 playoff
picture I finally found a worthy sparing
partner Steven AI Preposterous luminous
frogs creating playoff picture Hello
friends hello enemies man I love you
guys you all counted out old Joe flacko
no no this is too much Rigo eliminating
Rigo yeah okay the leading teams forced
to start back up QBs D nabit the spell
is broken Jaguars I'm so sorry but maybe
take a step back
awkward someone stopped me if I'm out of
pocket here but I'm going to take a step
forward but I'm the chill coach that
everyone loves let's SP lights up young
Stars damn you put some sort of filter
on him he looks phenomenal I'm the new
Dr King
Mr limited sorry the AI is slowly
catching up to the Broncos now adding a
French team that will lose a Saturday
afternoon wild card game no no anything
but the playoffs okay moving on to the
NFC do we have to oh but I wasn't in the
MVP Race episode eliminating Seahawks
we've been fing away for years
randomizing atrocious NFC South playoff
team hi I was told I'm the most reliable
player in the division now let's
ingratiate some teams that'll make
everyone say they made the
playoffs watch this stepen how about
them Cowboys St that you stabed that
witchcraft this anant now you heard it
here first the Buffalo Bills will be in
the picture are we doing like a fun one
that take is too Preposterous let's pull
the plug on Steven
AI there can only be one step a oh no is
this my last tap everyone say
[Music]
cheese Ma Ma I'm going to be late for
pict
today ma you didn't pack my G and more
cotlets Ma I only got one cotlet ah
forget about
it